R
GA
WYOMING.
>> WHAT I NEED Repor IRPEPITO'SS
TELLING ABC. BE SAFE.E'S LIKE A
CHILDREN LOVE HER.
O  ANDSOUND.
SHKIDS S THAT THE TS
BE
COMMUNITY AND THE, KW, SENSE IN
H
>> Reporter: THEY
>> IT'S ONLY 10:00 INED ALL
AFTERNOON YESTERDAY.
DOCUMENTED
JOURNEY IAA G
CHOCOLATE MELTED.
>> IT'S A RIVER OF KEEE IN
UTAH. JULY. PETITLAST HRDM HER T
THT TETO IN
AUGUST 3 FACEB SAYING
SHE WA C
AN.
HESTT WAS ON AFAMILY SD  SHE
OFFICERS FOUND BRIAN'S VAN AT
WITHOUT REPORTING R MISSINPETITN
>> W NEVERN A WORD
WITH BRIANter: POLICE IN MOAUTE.
>> WHAT'ING ON?G THIS M.L ISSUE
EMOTIONAL AND C. THE OFFICER'S G
SITUATION WAS A RESULT O
MENTAL HEALT
FILED.CE SAY THEY DON' WHAT, IFS
A LAWYER FOR LAUNDRIE FAMILY
LIFE TT THE RIGHT TEPFATHER WHWT
THING.
TNOW.
STOP WAIeporter: AT THIS
MULTIPLE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGESRE IES
PETITO'SISAPPEARANCE, INCLU
GB
OFFICES.FFICE JOINING TH
AN SAWERH ASKI
BRIAN ORBY ON
GET  TOU WITH BRIAN LAUNDRIE ST
>>BYTH HERFIANCE.UNDERSTAND YOU
PPENING?
>>E C THEY
E COME OUT THERE
ANE PANTO TALK
TO
RIGHT NOW I DON'T KNOW W
CONVERSATI E
OUR TEAM IT THERE ING TO.
I CAN TELL YOU THAN IS NOT
THERE, BUT THE OF E SATION I'M
>> I UST
ME AS MUCH A TFAMILY'S HOM
IT DOESN'T SING IS THECACOMPLA A
THEYD BECAUSE THEY HAD
OFFICERS, WHATEVER THAT MIGH
ATION
THAT THERE WAS GOING TO BE APEAA
ER
YOU SAID BRIAIS
THERE, IS HE JUST TAG TO
YOUR OFF
S
PARENTS, OR IS HE ACTUALLY  IN
IF SO, DO YOU KNOW WHY?
>>THS I'M AWARE RIGH
NOW.
WE A S TRE
FIRST TIME
AS YOUND ILET ME ONE OTHER THING
IN AN INTERVIEW.
JUST LISTETO A CLIP OF WHAT . W
TO HIM. I COUERY  I
CAN.
WOVE MORE. SO OBVIOUSLY,,
ALL OF THIS BETTERN
THERE WERE TENTHE RETURN
FA.ER REPORTED HEING.OU THINK H
WOULD BE ASKING, W IY ?THUS FARP
THE HAD TO BE SOME TYPE OF SATI
I'M A REASONABLE I
WOULD BELITHDO
.T WOULRTAINLSEEM S
ANYTHING IS SOMETHING
CHIEF, JTION
IS?AN  TOR
>> RIGHTN'S AT NOW.
U , HE COUE ANYWHERE.
WE E AND YOUR BEING WILLING T
YOU'R THE
FAMILYL LOOK TFICERS AND